main purpose to come to new zealand was
on becoming a physiotherapist in new
zealand
so i
i'm a physiotherapist in japan for 12
years
but just my license is not recognized to
work
so i had to go to university or take the
examination to pass
because i'm not like i have a family
here
so
it's it's quite difficult to belong to
something like a community for example
if i have a mother or if i have a
children
probably i can get into like a school
and community for example mum friend or
for example if i take my my kids to
swimming with paul and i can see some
families but because i'm here as a
physiotherapist only but i can see lots
of clients who helped me
improve my english and which is very
great
but
apart from that it's
yeah sometimes little bit of difficulty
if you don't do some community i think
so that's why i was very pleased to find
an english class
that's why i'm here now